speaking of anime adaptations though
there is one topic I would like to color
because it is quite timely yeah but uh
just yesterday actually reporting over
as of us recording this episode I found
or I guess [ __ ] found that somebody is
adapting killing stalking you mean it's
not a big deal this is the biggest
quoting killing stalking you mean when
Andaman you mean it's not an official
anime adaptation like everyone on
Twitter thinks it is okay it was like
the most is the original Twitter post
that blew this up said an official
adaptation and then in the replies to
that tweet they double down saying it
yeah it was all official but the thing
that caught my eye is the picture that
everyone was retweeting all right three
pictures of this tweet one of them was
like chaos Pop's Jim Lee what the [ __ ]
is a chaos UPS yeah yeah so like cuz cuz
Aki found that on a timeline and was
like holy [ __ ] they're making is killing
smoking item adaptation I'm like really
let me see and I saw the pictures I'm
like the first two legit yeah it was
like coming soon 2020 I was like oh [ __ ]
okay and then I looked at the last one
and it was like kay ops up studium like
yeah yeah right who what is the student
I legitimately had to look it up on
Wikipedia being like yeah baby it's just
one of them cuz you know recently
they've been so many [ __ ] Japanese
anime studio yeah I just come out with
like a ridiculous name so I'm like else
probably just one of those exactly I
looked it up and I'm like no it's
literally just one dude one dude but I
feel bad for this derivative making this
cuz like my god the amount of heights
they just got thrusted on them and
everyone's assuming this is like legit
yeah I mean how did the hype just happen
didn't they just literally just between
just the two it yeah the original tweet
I think as of us recording I think has
like forty thousand likes and like
twenty thousand retweets it's like wow
because killing stalking fans are
ruthlessly dedicated and also the thing
was the sworn Lora and the replies is
that people weren't questioning whether
like it was legit people would just
questioning should it get in that app
tation and that's the main argument I
think that's why it was getting so many
I think you should get an adaptation I
mean let me let me change the question
have you guys read it I've read the
first like what is it like cuz it came
out like stories right like season
i watch I've read the first season and I
quite liked it and you know it's a lot
well I feel like from what I've heard as
well the handles are quite well towards
the end yeah I did a video on it I
actually looked back on when I did my
video of it almost four years ago holy
[ __ ] was it that long ago yeah I
remember you releasing that like four
years ago and that's because I only
reviewed the first season because I
think the series ended like it was like
last year yeah yeah but it was like a
huge gap right so I've only really seen
or read like the first half of it and it
was you know it was marketed as like
mall it's a really hard call like
gruesome Yowies yeah you know all these
fan girls getting on it and I was like
okay I mean I don't know if I'm gonna
enjoy it as much because I'm not exactly
the target demographic but I'll give it
a go and it was like a genuinely good
story like yeah it had Yowie elements in
it but you know I'm an adult I can
handle that yeah other than that if you
take away the yoke elements it's just a
really really good horror mystery but
when I saw that they were gonna make a
quote-unquote anime adaptation for it I
was like I don't I don't know because
immediately what I thought of is all of
these other like over sexualized series
getting anime adaptations recently
because as someone who hasn't read it
seems like it's a very sexual story that
would have to be heavily said it is is
well I think it also has such like its
divided a lot of community cuz I think a
lot of people really sexualize it yeah
when it's just a really [ __ ] up
dynamic yeah and a lot of I mean a lot
of a really deep [ __ ] of like
possessiveness and all that but if
you're thinking about reading it it's
it's a lot like going to it with caution
definitely be here for the age of 80 we
have I mean I I think you should read it
but then also like I can totally
recommend you not to read it like it's
your life would be totally fine if you
don't read it yeah maybe I love the
anime instead
okay my opinion they're talking about
the anime like I said a failure I feel
bad for the this person because a lot of
people are putting a lot of hype on it
but also what I saw it's a one-man job
like you starts doing everything and I
don't know if it's a guy or girl but
they seem to be in charge of they seem
to be 3d modelers I think right what
they're traders and I saw the
voice-acting casting call and as someone
who's you know done a lot of voice
acting casting calls I've made my own
I've worked with a lot of professional
ones like it is not normal I'd say I
don't even know I don't to be moved
because they I don't think they're like
that experience and I think other voice
actors are helping them with it but
right first of all normally you don't
name who's gotten what role publicly
right so on this casting call document
which I think we even maybe show on
screen for a second it says like one
person who has the role and it's showing
publicly that's not normally the case
normally it's just here are the lines
audition for it [ __ ] yeah and the way
it's laid out is really odd and it's
just over I mean over Twitter isn't that
weird but there's no mention of pay or
anything like I guess I mean it is a
fan-made project but normally still you
say if it's paid or not yeah you
normally say how you know how many lines
they're gonna be it just I don't know it
looks like it belongs on like casting
call Club which is an amateur voice
acting website yeah which makes me
uneasy because if it is gonna be a USB
microphone kind of deal it's not gonna
sound good cuz there was no there was no
hey here's the minimum requirements you
need a sentry room there's nothing was
just if you want to audition yeah and I
saw the replies to this thread and it
was like all thirteen Ewald sounding
girls auditioning yeah but that's
because the main [ __ ] like readership
talking are thirteen-year-old girls yeah
it should be from purely based on
context it should not be it is just
worrying with these kind of things as
well because normally like when I've
done plus eighteen project I normally
ask for proof of ID even if I cast
someone like they need to show me their
ID and this should definitely be one of
the situations where I like those those
precautions should be taken yeah even if
it's fan-made right like yeah not a good
look for you if you you're getting 13
old girls to voice in your thing about
like it's still very early days
I mean it's from what it sounds like it
sounds like a situation where someone
just way too much press got way too much
press way too quickly because I have no
doubt that they probably have no [ __ ]
experience because I saw on their
Twitter actually just this morning
yeah they tweeted out being like oh my
god after someone retweeted my thing
I've gained like ten thousand Twitter
followers in like overnight and like you
know this person obviously like came
from Lees pretty much close to zero for
yes so for them that's a lot yeah that's
that's a lot of like pressure just
immediately built up on that yeah
because you're going off to such like I
don't wanna say iconic but like a very
like very very dedicated series no I
think it's not just that as well because
I think what really built up the hype as
well as we're in like this environment
now where webtoons anime it kavya are
being major so it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be it wouldn't have been so
surprising to say killing Stalkings
getting an anime as opposed to like last
year even two years ago where you know
we didn't have any presidents for that
now with tower of god airing and god of
high school and nobly all guessing
animes it's like maybe we're in a new
era where people are expecting that's
their favorite webtoons or their
favorite web comics or whatever country
is could get anime adaptations